I don't give a that people don't
take me serious I care about the results
I'm feeling really blocked posting on
social media um especially because I'm a
hypnotherapist I know that you know
there lot of misperceptions around
hypnosis so I'm so concerned about being
so professional and I think it's really
blocking me from authentically posting
content is this about people's
subjective opinions or is this about
rules that you have to stay within the
category of work that you do I it's more
about people's opinions that's what I
thought thank God because that game we
can win maybe I can hypnotize you right
now
ready snap three
times and you're gonna understand the
following Ramona you are no longer in
high school in junior high people making
fun of you no longer
matters